MALE SPEAKER: We're in
for real treat today,
we're here with Dr. Bernard
Roth who also goes by Bernie.
So a little bit
about Dr. Roth, he's
the Rodney H. Adams
professor of engineering,
and the academic director
of the Hasso Plattner
Institute of Design, also
known as the d.school
at Stanford University.
He graduated from the
City College of New York
with a degree in
mechanical engineering.
He's a native New Yorker, and
he earned a master's degree
and a PhD In
mechanical engineering
from Columbia University.
In 2012, the Columbia University
Engineering School Alumni
Association awarded him the
prestigious Egleston Medal
for Distinguished
Engineering Achievement.
And he lives in
Stanford, California.
We have a pretty interactive
presentation today,
he's got a mic for Q&A.
So it'll be good hour.
Without further ado, Dr. Roth.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNARD ROTH: Thank you
for coming out here,
I have Google stock so
I won't waste your time.
[LAUGHTER]
This book that I wrote
is an expression of stuff
that's been my life for
a very, very long time.
When I first came out
to the valley in 1962,
it was a very different place.
Not only was there no Google,
there were no start ups,
essentially.
Hewlett Packard was
the big place in town.
A lot of people would
always-- my students
all would say that
some day they're
going to start a
company and all that,
and there wasn't venture money.
Most of them never
did, and it reminded me
of this story in
"The Iceman Cometh"
where these guys are
sitting in the bar all day,
and they never leave
the bar, and they just
talk about going out
and crossing the street.
So I felt, really, that
there was something
missing in people's education.
So I started a class,
which eventually is called,
"The Designer in Society."
The name doesn't mean anything.
It's just a name.
And the idea was, everyone got
to do a term project which they
chose, which was either get
rid of a problem in your life
or do something you've always
want to do and you've never
before.
And it could be things
like jumping out
of airplanes or whatever.
It doesn't have to be anything
academic, or engineering,
or stuff like that.
And to fill the 10
weeks between that,
I had to do a lot of stuff.
So I developed a lot of
exercises and readings
and things like that.
And it's been going on since
1970, so that's a long time.
Eventually, various
circumstances of my life
led to, "Well, I'm stuck
here on my sabbatical,
I might as well do
something useful."
So I decided I write a book.
Now the last time
I had that feeling
was when I was young
assistant professor
on my first
sabbatical in Holland,
and I started to write a book.
And it turned out to be
525 pages of all equations.
It took me nine years.
One reviewer said it was the
best book of the century.
Another said it's the best
kinematics book ever written.
And it sold 2,000 copies.
[LAUGHTER]
This book took less
than a year to write.
It's been in process
for three years.
It's been out two days.
Amazon has run out of copies.
It went to the number one
list in business and advice
kind of things.
It's in the top hundred.
The staff has chosen to read it.
So this is amazing.
No equations.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's like bracketing my
life from serious scientist
to fuzzy guy.
But the fuzzy guy
stuff is useful.
It's amazing-- the
story-- they make me cry,
a lot of these stories
because it's changed
a lot of people's lives.
And the funny thing
is, I thought it was me
and my magic in the classroom,
my insightfulness and all that.
But people have
been having galleys
for a couple of
months around, and I
keep getting the same stories.
"Bernie, I picked up
your book and I did this,
and I did that" and
all that, including
the woman who used to work
for the Washington Post,
and now she works
at the d.school.
And she does our blog
page and all that stuff.
And she was close to me from
the beginning with the book.
And when she got to read
the final copy, she said,
"You know, I'm going to
stop trying to do something,
I'm going to write my own book."
And she's getting up
at 3:00 in the morning
every morning writing a book.
So I want warn you,
this can ruin your life.
[LAUGHTER]
And the other insight
I had coming in here,
if these two guys called Larry
and Serge had taken my course,
this company would be three
times bigger than it already
is.
But somehow they escaped
without seeing me there.
Anyhow, I want to talk
to you, basically,
about life, and problem
solving, and things like that.
And if you read one of
the reviews on Amazon,
you can read his reviews.
My buddy, Bob Sutton, who wrote
a book, "Don't Hire Assholes,"
or something like
that, he put up,
"Well, Bernie thinks about the
world different than everyone
else, but it seems to
be very successful.
So maybe you ought to
try some of his ideas."
So I'm going to give you some
ideas, which up until Tuesday
were just Bernie's bullshit,
but now it's written.
[LAUGHTER]
So, this is real.
This is real, folks.
I've been getting away with
it for all these years,
but now I can give you
book where it's real.
I started this stuff--
there's a company
IDEO, you may or may not know
them, which are my students.
For years I would do
my stuff and people
would say, "Well how's that?"
I would say, "Well, that's
what they do at IDEO,
so it's got to be OK."
So I had someone to point to.
Now I don't need to
hide behind IDEO.
I can just point to by book.
OK, so what do we
want to talk about?
Well, what I want to talk about
first is solving problems.
So the issue is,
you're all smart.
Like Larry Page said, you all
deserve to be here, right?
So you got past that hurdle,
whoever reads that stuff.
And I deal at Stanford
with a lot of smart people,
and have a lot of smart friends,
and I'm pretty smart myself.
So how come we all mess up,
and we can't solve problems?
In our lives we have problems.
In our work we have problems.
How come we can't just do what
we want to do and it flows?
Well, you know, it's illogical.
Even if we grasp for something
new, if you're really smart
you should be able to solve it.
So what is it that happens?
So I've noticed-- I have a life.
I've lived a long time.
And I've had a lot of problems.
I notice my family
has a lot of problems.
My friends have problems.
We do a lot of work
at the d.school, a lot
of problems around the world.
Before that, in the
design group in ME
we would do a lot of
projects for companies.
How come people get stuck?
And I said, this is very
scientific, in my view
99.999% of the time,
it's because you're
working on the wrong problem.
It's as simple as that.
And what you've done is
you've taken an answer,
and you assume
that's the question.
I'll explain that more later.
And it's not a good answer
to what you want to work on.
So even if you solved it, it
really would kind of a crummy
kludge.
But once you find the
right problem to work on,
it's generally easy
sailing and sometimes it's
right in front of you.
So I'll give you a simple
example in my own life,
and there's two points to this.
The first point is, whatever
I tell you right now is not
like an inoculation for life.
You have to keep looking at this
stuff, and it's a little hard.
That's the tricky
part about it, just
knowing about it is not enough.
You have to kind of check
yourself all the time.
So go back some years, and
I'm doing my guru number
at KTH, which is the MIT
of Sweden in Stockholm.
And things are going
great, but at night, I'm
losing sleep all
night long because I'm
near the retirement age.
In those days, there was a
thing called, "retirement age."
And I'm deciding, should I
retire or shouldn't I retire?
And I'm really losing
sleep over that.
In the middle of one
of my lectures I go,
"hey, maybe I should apply
some of the stuff to myself."
So that night I go home
and I say-- the trick is,
the starkness is to
ask yourself what
it would for you if
you solve your problem.
So I said to myself,
"Well, what's my problem?"
My problem is deciding whether
I should retire or not.
And I said, "Well, what would do
for me if I solve the problem?"
I could stop worrying about
whether to retire or not.
Simple as that.
So, the problem is
not the decision,
the problem is to stop worrying.
So how do you stop worrying
about whether to retire or not?
It's a no brainer.
You just stop worrying about it.
So I stopped.
And it's been many,
many years, and I never
worried about again.
So it's a kind of
crummy example,
but that's the essence
of it, that you
have the wrong problem.
And often it's a little
subtle change in the thing,
and you think you're
dealing with something
which is life and death, and
it's not the right thing.
So that's the model.
So let's-- can we
write on this board?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
BERNARD ROTH: Good.
Oh, and it has
markers, fantastic.
OK, so let's take an example so
this becomes really concrete.
And then we'll
apply to your life.
So what I do with Stanford
students is this one.
We'll do it with you guys too.
So let's say, oh,
you're having trouble
deciding getting married.
So let's say your problem
is how to get married.
And you've tried everything.
Most people it's not an issue.
They get married or
don't get married,
but they don't worry about it.
But let's say in
your case you're
really concerned about this.
You've done everything.
You've joined many
computer dating services.
In the old days you would go
to every bar on the Camino, all
of that kind of stuff.
And your friends are fixing
you up, and nothing works.
Your parents are on your case.
And your older brother
is waiting for you
to get out of the way
so he could get married
to his true love, but
he can't get married
because you haven't
gotten married, whatever
it is, that whole drama.
So let's say it just
doesn't work for you.
So, you're stuck.
And my method says,
probably you're
stuck because this is
the wrong question.
And the way you find what
the right question is,
you say what would it do
for me if I solve this.
What would it do for
me if I got married?
So somebody give me an
answer, what would it
do for you if you got married.
Someone.
AUDIENCE: Your parents
will stop bugging you.
BERNARD ROTH: Say it again.
AUDIENCE: Your parents
will stop bugging you.
BERNARD ROTH: OK great.
All right, great.
So how to get parents
to stop bugging you.
OK, so that's the problem.
So the question is, how
do you get your parents
to stop bugging you?
Well, even if you got
married they might not
stop bugging you,
because then they're
going to want grandchildren,
blah, blah, blah.
So if they're going
to bug you, they're
going to keep bugging you.
So it wouldn't even solve
that problem, often.
And that's the problem
with this thing.
If it's hard, it's often
because it won't even
solve the problem.
Because you'll marry
the wrong person,
they'll bug you about that.
Well you know, there's a lot
of ways they can bug you.
But the question is now,
once you've got this,
this is a bigger solution
space because there
are lots of ways to get your
parents to stop bugging you
including this, let's
say, or maybe not this.
Either way, it doesn't matter.
So how could you get your
parents to stop bugging you?
You could move to the other
end of the earth, right?
You could do the send them
on a trip around the world.
You could tell them
how much you love them.
You could get your brother or
sister to call them every day,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
If they're divorced,
you can get them
each romantic
relationships so they
don't worry about you so much.
There's a million
ways to do that, OK.
So that's the idea, basically.
And if that didn't work, why
would you want your parents
to stop bugging you?
Play with me some more.
AUDIENCE: Why?
BERNARD ROTH: What would it do
for you if your parents stopped
bugging you?
AUDIENCE: I wouldn't
be as stressed.
BERNARD ROTH: Say that again.
AUDIENCE: I wouldn't
be as stressed.
BERNARD ROTH: OK, all
right, so that's great.
So how to be less stressed.
OK, so now that's
really interesting
because, again, there
will be lots of ways
and they may have nothing
to do with your parents.
They could bug you,
it wouldn't matter.
If I was enlightened-- if I
was an enlightened being it
doesn't matter what you say.
There's no way you could bug me.
It has nothing to
do with that, OK.
And certainly getting
married might not
make you less stressed at all.
It might make you more stressed.
So if your real problem was
how to get less stressed,
none of this will help you.
So that's what the
idea gets at-- the idea
is to find a problem
which is the real problem.
So this is hypothetical
and may or may not
ring a bell with you.
The test for all this stuff is
whether works in your own life.
So I want you to take a moment
now and think of a real problem
your life.
Now I don't want like,
"Peace in the world forever,"
stuff like that.
I want something that's
part of your life.
It could be a work problem.
It could be a social problem.
But something, really,
that you lose sleep over.
And just think of that, and
just make a simple sentence.
If you have something
to write on it's
good to do that, if you don't,
you can do it in your head.
I know you're brilliant
enough to hang onto it.
But I want to
start at this level
here with something
that bugs you
in your life that doesn't work
and you'd like to be rid of it.
OK, now this stuff really works.
I guarantee you it works,
money back guarantee.
If you do it, it works.
If you don't do it, it
doesn't work by definition.
So please give it
a shot, no matter
how reluctant you may
think, or how happy you
may think you are.
Think of something in your
life that doesn't work.
Just think of it as a
simple sentence like how to,
or some simple problem issue.
OK, so let's play my game
and that game would be,
what would it do for you if that
were gone in from your life?
If you solve that issue,
what would it do for you?
Again, make it a simple sentence
and make it into a problem.
So that's the thing
you really want
to be going after, not the
thing you started with.
So you're converting it.
You're re-framing the
problem into something
that, if you solve this problem,
it would take care of it
for you, and you are going
to deal with that directly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Isn't that way of
thinking a little selfish,
though?
BERNARD ROTH: One more time.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that way of
thinking a little selfish?
BERNARD ROTH: Selfish?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
If your problem includes
not only yourself,
but people surrounding you--
BERNARD ROTH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --answering what would
it do for you and answering,
for example, how you can be less
stressed about it doesn't mean
that it makes a difference in
the people who you want to--
BERNARD ROTH: Sure,
OK I understand
what you're saying
hypothetically,
do you have a specific
problem in mind?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I'm Greek.
BERNARD ROTH: Greek, I
know about Greeks, yes.
Some of my best
friends are Greek.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so
my problem right now
would be, for example, how
to make sure that my family
and friends back home are good.
BERNARD ROTH: Good, OK, OK good.
Stop, stop, OK.
So my friend, Panos, just had
his daughter marry a Greek guy
which makes him very nervous.
And he said, in Greece
what happened a week ago,
he was the only bank
in Greece operating.
I understand what
you're talking about,
but the point simply
is you're holding
what I'm saying incorrect.
If you're really losing sleep
about your parents and all
that that's fine.
What we do for you what
are you losing sleep over
it's like how could your
parents be-- frame it.
What's the problem?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
how can I make sure
that the situation is solved?
Like, is there anything
I can do as a person
to help the situation?
BERNARD ROTH:
Yeah, I understand.
So your question
is, "what can I do
to help the
situation in Greece?"
Is that the idea?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BERNARD ROTH: OK,
now the game is,
what would it do
for you if you could
help the situation in Greece?
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess
everything goes back
to stress, right?
BERNARD ROTH: Now, look,
the thing to understand
is if you could help
the situation in Greece,
you would do it.
You are frustrated,
you are-- you
know there's a story
I love is this one.
A drunk is working along
and he hits a lamppost.
He walks along and
he hits a lamppost.
And finally says, "I give up,
they've got me surrounded."
But if you're not drunk,
you see the lamppost
and you walk around it.
And that's the problem,
you're hitting a lamppost
because the situation
in Greece is terrible,
and your relatives
are in distress,
and there's nothing
you can do about it.
Right?
OK, so now, what
are you going to do?
AUDIENCE: Is there nothing
you can do about it?
BERNARD ROTH: I
don't know, so what
are you going to do about it?
AUDIENCE: That's
what I'm thinking.
BERNARD ROTH: OK, good.
How long have you been
thinking about it?
AUDIENCE: Months.
BERNARD ROTH: Months,
and so the indication
is, you can't do much
about it right now.
I'm not in any way
trivializing it.
trivializing your feelings.
And you could do that,
but I'm saying for you,
what is it doing for you to
think about that Greek thing?
AUDIENCE: I guess if I made
a the situation a little bit
different, even for
one person that I know,
even for one person
that I don't know,
that would make me
happier with my life.
BERNARD ROTH:
Good, that's great.
So why don't you do one
thing to make someone happy?
Who's stopping you?
AUDIENCE: I'm doing
for one person.
But then I'm thinking, how
can I make people around me
more considerate
of the situation?
If everybody around me
donated a small amount--
BERNARD ROTH: OK, so
who's stopping you
from getting people to do that?
AUDIENCE: I'm trying.
Facebook is helping.
BERNARD ROTH: OK, well am I
stopping you from doing that?
AUDIENCE: No but I'm asking,
if I was wondering like,
OK, the situation in
Greece makes me stressed,
how am I going to
deal with my stress
instead of dealing
with the situation?
BERNARD ROTH: You know
what's interesting,
you think you're helping the
situation by being stressed.
You actually might help
it by not being stressed.
I had a woman once in my
workshop with a similar idea,
her problem was
she wanted to get
her daughter into a good college
and she was very stressed.
And her realization was that
the issue was really her stress,
not the daughter
going to college.
Because once her daughter
went into a good college,
she'd find something else
to be stressed about.
And her stress didn't
help the daughter
get into a good college or not.
So she's dealing with
the wrong problem.
I'm not saying it's an
issue that doesn't exist.
I'm not saying
getting married is
an issue that does not exist.
I'm just saying it's the wrong
problem for you at the moment,
and you're not handling it well
because you're a smart person.
You have Facebook, you
have all these things,
and somehow it's not working
for you, what you're doing,
or it is.
If it is, great,
I'm not against it.
I'm happy for you.
I'm saying, you having
something, hypothetically,
that you're losing sleep over,
and you've been working on it,
it doesn't work.
And how come such a smart
person like you can't solve it?
Well, it's the wrong
problem for you to work on.
It's simply that
it's a hard problem,
there's a lot of people
in the world trying
to solve that problem.
So you've put yourself
in a situation which
is the wrong thing
to be working on
and you could make
yourself over the issue,
and it's still not going to
change it, do you understand?
So you have to be
honest with yourself,
and this is all hard to
say, but you you're lying
to yourself in some way,
and you're lying to yourself
because you have a
certain self image either
as a daughter, or the
family member who's
concerned with these things.
But if you look at what
you're really doing,
and what's going on, it's
a thing for yourself.
Now it sounds selfish,
but it's not selfish.
So let's just hang
out for a few minutes
because we'll get
to it in a minute
and we'll get to what I
call "reasons are bullshit,"
we'll get to that
in a second, OK.
Anyone else have any problems
understanding this idea?
Now believe me, it really works.
I do this every
year in a class, I
have this colleague who every
year says, "this is amazing,
Bernie."
It works every year
I come and do it.
So why does he say every
year this is amazing
and he needs me to come
into the room to do it?
Because he just knows it
intellectually and he hasn't
put into his life,
and as I told you
in my first anecdote
of myself, who
does this stuff all the time,
still got caught not doing it.
So the thing about
it, it's not only
good to know it intellectually,
you have to apply it,
and you have to realize
that every time-- if you're
stuck it's a tool.
Believe me, it works,
I guarantee it works.
I've done it with thousands of
the people around the world.
It's a simple idea,
if you're stuck,
what would it do for you if
you solved the problem, that
re-frames the problem for you.
If you're stuck again,
go one more level.
Never go more than
two levels above,
because there you get to the
ultimate question mark of life,
and the guys in India who
are blind from looking
at the sun and all
that kind of stuff.
You don't want to
be working at Google
to go more than two levels.
And the trouble is,
you lie to yourself,
and it's sort of in
the realm of what
she's doing because she has a
certain self image of herself
as this is good person.
And a good person, of course,
wants to do something in Greece
and she's not doing it
so she's frustrated.
But the thing is, she wants
to make herself feel better,
clearly, and that sounds
selfish, but it's not selfish.
And she could do
better for the people
there if she were more
forthright with the thing.
So that's one or hurdles
with solving problems,
once you get the right problem
it works out fine, in general.
Sometimes, you
sabotage yourself.
And you sabotage
yourself with reasons.
And the problem is you don't
say, "I have an excuse."
You don't say, "I have
an excuse, Bernie."
You say, "the reason is this--"
and the thing to understand
is, in terms of
personal behavior,
all reasons are bullshit.
You have no idea why
you're doing stuff,
you just do it and you
make up a reason for it.
And that's called being
a reasonable person.
[LAUGHTER]
If you don't have a reason,
you're not a reasonable person,
right?
If you say, "Why did you
come here to talk at Google?"
If I say, "I don't
know," this guy's crazy.
But if I say I came
because I was invited
or I came because I want
to spread my wisdom,
it's all reasonable, right?
If I take this guy, he's
looking at his thing,
I punch him in the nose, he
says, "Why did you do that?"
If I say, "I don't know."
I'm not reasonable.
If you punch him in
the nose and say,
"You look like the guy
who raped my neighbor."
Then it's a good reason, right?
So, it's on that absurd
level that we do our reasons,
and there have been
a lot of studies
that show that
people's brains are
such-- the part of the brain
that determines what you do
usually fires before the
part that figures out
the reason for doing it.
So usually you do stuff
and then you say, why?
And my favorite
example is, right now
my mouth is a little dry.
Now if you say to me, "Why's
your mouth dry, Bernie?"
I'd say, "well, I'm
speaking a lot."
That's logical, right?
But I don't tell you that I
was out last night drinking,
I don't tell you I'm
always dehydrated.
I don't tell you a
lot of things which
don't make me look as good
as, "I'm speaking now."
So, in anything you do there's
a million reasons for it,
and it's a matter of the
one that you pick out.
To say something is a reason
for your behavior this a lie,
and you need it
to be reasonable.
So what I do is, if
you ask me reason,
I'll tell you something, I'm
not going to be a jerk about it.
But if I know when I say it
that that reason is bullshit,
then I'm going to say I'm
not going to do that again,
and I'll do it again, but
eventually I'll stop doing it.
So you have to realize that, in
fact, anything you call reason
is not the reason for anything.
So I don't want you to
take my word for it,
I want you to do a
little experiment.
I want you to turn to
a person next to you
and so I want you to do a little
exercise which goes like this.
So you're going to work
with me, you're lucky.
And the way it
goes is like this--
I've done this workshop
a million times
with the people I
work with at Stanford,
my whole group in the design
group before the d.school.
So, in our meeting
if some guy gets up--
we have one professor who's
always crabbing about stuff.
So he gets up and he
says, "Well the reason
I can't do this is
the Dean said--"
Everyone goes "That's
a good reason."
With the emphasis on the O's,
which means it's bullshit.
So in my parlance,
"It's a good reason"
means it's not a reason at all.
So if she's my
partner here, I say,
"the reason why
my mouth is dry is
because I'm talking too much."
She says, "That's
a good reason."
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: That's a good reason.
BERNARD ROTH: OK, now I
say, the reason I came here
is because I was invited.
AUDIENCE: That's a good reason.
BERNARD ROTH: OK, so everything
I said is true, OK, it's true,
but it's not the reason.
Because I could have been
invited and not come,
I could have come
uninvited also.
There's a lot of
different things--
[LAUGHTER]
--so it's kind of funny,
you know what I mean?
And why did I come?
Did I come because I want
you to think I'm a great man?
Did I come because I
want to sell books?
There's a million
reasons in there,
and I'm going to
pick the one that's
going to make me look the
coolest, that's my self image.
I want you to experience
that for yourself.
So what I'm going to ask you
to do is turn to your partner
and I'm going to first tell
her a whole bunch of reasons,
she's going to tell me
each one is a good reason,
and then at some point
I'll say switch roles.
And then she'll
tell me her reasons,
and I'll say "That's a good
reason." for each of them.
OK, you get the idea?
And if you do that, you're
gonna get a reward from me.
All right, so please
turn to a partner.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
And if you don't have a
partner, raise your hand.
AUDIENCE: A reason for what?
BERNARD ROTH: What's that?
For why we're here?
BERNARD ROTH: For anything--
(YELLING OVER CROWD)
one minute, one minute, one
minute, one minute, one minute,
one minute.
He asked me a very [INAUDIBLE]
question, a reason for what?
Reasons for anything, but take
real things in your life, OK.
Like whatever happens in your
life, the reason I'm here,
or the reason I'm going
home tonight, or the reason
I went to the movies yesterday.
Just real stuff in
your life and just
put a reason for your behavior.
So the reason is for your
behavior, real things
in your life, the behavior, OK?
AUDIENCE: And can you
say it's a good reason
or it's a bad reason?
BERNARD ROTH: No, always,
"It's a good reason."
They're all bad.
What you don't understand,
she asked, can you
say any reason-- there is no
good reason, this is a joke,
always it's a bad reason.
They're bad in the sense
that they're not uniquely
the reason for anything.
They're a reason and the
fact that you're singling
that out is the problem, OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
OK, thank you, thank
you, thank you.
You get the idea.
So one of the ones she does
did triggered something
in me which I love very much.
I was at a PhD exam up at
Stanford in the ed school
and we're about to start but
there was a professor who
was coming late, she happened
to be a person from Berkeley.
And they said, "Oh she's
coming from Berkeley."
Like that's OK to be late.
And she just triggered that,
she said, "The reason I was late
is I came from the
other building."
That's the bullshit I'm trying
to get you to understand.
[LAUGHTER]
We do that to ourselves all
the time, it's just an excuse,
she didn't leave in time,
among other reasons.
And that's what we do, so it's
so obvious when you see it.
And the problem
is that I've just
ruined your life because you're
always using bullshit reasons
and all the people in your life
are using bullshit reasons.
So the first thing
I've got to do in order
to make, at least, that
you won't get killed
and lose your relationship, do
not try this at home, please
do not try this.
It's OK to say, "hey we had this
crazy professor today at work,
and he said reasons
are bullshit."
That's OK, but
what you can't say
is your reasons are bullshit.
I have never said
that to my wife,
that to my friends,
I've never said it
to my family, I never
say it to the guys
I bike with who
are full of bullshit
reasons for everything.
Do not do that, give
them a copy of my book,
that's the way out of that.
That will do it, really.
Do not-- just fix yourself.
But it's so simple
when you see that, when
you see how we use
reasons all the time,
they're just excuses, and once
you get past that you'll change
your behavior if you want to.
Now it doesn't happen,
necessarily, the next time,
but it will change.
And I've lived through
that many times.
So the idea is, it's a
really good framework
to have in the back of your mind
that all reasons are bullshit.
And we need them socially,
we have to be reasonable.
But we don't need to keep
repeating the same thing
if we realize what
I just is bullshit
and I don't want
to do it again, I
don't want to come late again.
And then you will
come late again,
but eventually you'll learn
to leave 10 minutes earlier,
If you want to.
And if you don't you'll
have a good life without it,
but that's the point.
Yes, Let me get-- I've been
remiss in giving people
the mic.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: That's OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So I totally agree--
BERNARD ROTH: OK.
AUDIENCE: --but I
wonder whether you
think that for everything we
do there's a lot of reasons
and there isn't one
predominant one,
and just arbitrarily
do something.
Or there's some deep
reason that we're
not aware of that's
somehow subconscious
and is driving our behavior.
BERNARD ROTH: Well, my belief
is that there are many reasons
and there's a veil--
so the ultimate reason
is some great ancestor had
sex, if they didn't, you
wouldn't be here.
So that's the reason
for everything,
but that seems absurd.
But it goes that way,
you know, there's
a whole hierarchy of reasons.
Some seem more
relevant because they
are more recent and all that.
However, what you
choose to do is not
necessarily related to what
seems like the obvious reason
right now.
So, our friend from Greece
left, but there may be deep--
I don't know her
well and stuff like,
and I understand what
she's talking about,
of course, it's
not unreasonable,
but that reason
for that behavior
may go back to her childhood.
It may go back to
what her mother did,
or how her parents rated her.
It's not as simple
as you think is,
we're all very
complex beings, we're
formed by heredity
and environment,
and the things we do,
we just do and then
we make things that make
our self image seem OK.
But if we remove the things, you
still have that behavior often,
or not, I don't know.
And who cares?
I mean I don't care.
It's not my research, I
don't care about that.
What I care about is functioning
and making myself a better
functioning person and having
a better life for myself
and the people around you.
And I'm telling you if
you get rid of reasons
it will work much better.
A simple example in my life,
I get from China, and India,
and all over the world maybe
three or four emails a week,
"Professor, I'd like to
come and do a PhD with you."
And I used to give
all-- I'm sorry,
I don't have enough money in my
group, I'm going on sabbatical,
and it's all bullshit because
if I want to take anybody
there's nothing that would
stop me from taking someone.
So the bottom line is, I just
don't want to take that person,
and I just say, "I'm
sorry I can't help you."
I get most back a, "thank
you for answering my email,
professor."
When I used to
give reasons they'd
go-- if I say I don't have
enough money in my research
group, "I have a rich
uncle, he'll do this--"
and it goes on, and on, and on,
and it's totally dysfunctional.
I'm not going to take
the person anyway.
So just trying to make them
feel nice with the reasons
actually makes it worse.
Often we give reasons to make
it feel nicer for someone else,
we're really trying to make
it easier for ourselves.
If you just say what you
do without the excuses
and the reasons, is fine.
"I came late, sorry."
Without why you-- I don't care
why, you came late, that's all.
It's as simple as that.
I don't need the
bullshit reasons.
So really it's a
very simple thing,
I have a chapter titled
"reasons are bullshit."
Believe me, try it
out, believe me,
just try not to give reasons.
But again, don't tell anyone
else their reasons are
bullshit.
And people are
great teachers, you
should learn from everyone
in your environment.
If you see what they do,
just don't do the same thing
yourself.
OK, so that's kind of the
next point I want to make,
we're getting close to time.
I'm going to do one more shtick,
unless you have questions,
we could do that first.
Anyone have some questions, or
I'll rant on a little bit more.
OK, so last thing that's really
important, so what we first
talked about is
essentially re-framing,
to make sure you working
on a problem that's
the right problem.
The next thing is not to let
yourself off with excuses,
to actually have the right thing
that-- just take responsibility
for your behavior.
And if it's not what
you want, change it,
it's as simple as that.
And the next thing
is, people confuse
two states, which are
very different states,
as the same thing.
And that is this whole
idea of trying and doing.
And there's this big
line that people always
get from Star
Wars, which I hate,
"There's no try, just do."
I hate to contradict, but
there is try, and there is do.
And I understand the
context they use it in,
but they're two different
states and the problem
is we confuse the idea
between trying and doing.
And if you try and do
something, it might happen,
it might not happen.
It's just that way and if
there's some obstacles,
you're just going to not do it.
If you're doing
something, then it
doesn't matter if there
are obstacles or not,
you're gonna do it.
Whatever it takes, you're gonna
do it, it's as simple as that.
My great story on that happened
a few months ago, my wife and I
were driving in San Fransisco
and there's a theater called
the Roxy theater.
You probably all live
in San Fransisco, right?
So you all know the Roxy
in the mission district.
And they had a huge
line, bigger than ever,
and I noticed on
the marquee that it
was a movie about a band and
the band was going to be there.
I said, "That's going
to be great, let's go."
And my wife said, "No, no,
I'm tired, let's go home."
I said, "Come on,
come on, let's go."
She said, "OK, we'll go."
I said, "Get out of the
car, buy the tickets,
I'll go find a parking space."
So 10 minutes later, I come
back and she's standing in front
the box office, not on line.
I say, "Well, why
aren't you on line?"
and she said,
"They're sold out."
I said, "Well, so what, why
didn't you get some tickets."
She said, "They're sold out."
I said, "Come on."
So I go, and of course
five minutes later, I
have two tickets and we
go in, and she was right,
it was a crummy show and
we shouldn't have gone.
But the point simply
is, the she was trying,
she really do want to
go, but she was trying,
and being sold out is the best
excuse or reason in the world.
They're sold out, what can I do?
Now, give me a break,
just because they're
sold out, if you really want
to go to something you can go.
It's just a matter of price,
or whatever it takes, or luck.
But there's certainly
someone in this long line
in San Francisco who is going
to have an extra ticket,
or sell me their ticket if I
give them enough money, right?
It's not a problem to get
into the Roxy theater which
is crummy and smelly and
all that stuff if you want,
but it's a great example.
She was trying, she really was,
she was honestly willing to go.
She was giving it a
try, but the minute
she got an obstacle
it was, "whew, OK,
we're done with that."
I was going to go no matter
what, no matter what it took.
It turned out it
was pretty easy,
but I would have gone
to a much higher level
of doing if I wanted to because
I was determined to do it.
Well that's an example of
what happens in our lives
all the time.
If we get obstacles and we're
here, we're like the drunk,
they've got us surrounded,
I can't do anything.
And if you're not drunk, it's
just simple walking around it
and you do it.
I cannot tell you, there's
so many people who 've taken
our workshop, there was some
guys from digital TV took
an exec ed workshop
I was running.
There's a thing I
do, an exercise,
where you try and take
a cup away from me,
and if you try you don't
succeed and stuff like that.
So, they went back to
digital TV and they
had a project they wanted
to do and the managers said
no, we have no room,
you guys can't do it.
And they tell me
they said, we huddled
and we said, "Let's take
the cup away from Bernie."
And what they did
is, they set up
an office right in the hallway,
and they started working,
and eventually they got
space and moved ahead
with the project.
But it's an example, a lot of
people say no all the time.
I don't know how
it is at Google,
here they probably say yes 10
times or something like that.
But whatever it is,
you do the hurdles,
and it's a question of trying
or doing, and they're both OK.
That's what I don't like about
"There's no try, just do."
I think, if you were in the
doing state, that's true,
but if you're trying
state, it's OK.
And you could try and do
stuff and if it works,
it works if it doesn't
work, you don't
have to live your life
at this great intensity
that some people do.
So to summarise,
if you get stuck,
it's important to
realize if you're
working on the right problem.
And I gave you a very easy
way re-frame the problem.
Then, if you're
going to execute,
you've got to make sure
you don't let yourself off
with bullshit reasons
called excuses.
And just remembering all
reasons are bullshit is true,
and you don't need a reason,
you just do what you do.
And then the other
thing is to make sure
which state you're in.
If you're trying to
do it, that's fine,
and if you're doing
it, it's fine.
But they're not the same state.
And you could switch
one to the other.
If I have to kill you
in order to do it,
I might decide I
don't want to do it,
I ought to decide I
don't want to do it.
It's fine to switch,
it's just not
fine to think you're one
when you're in the other one,
and the one that
we mainly confuse
is we think we're doing
when we we're actually
in the trying state.
So that's kind of getting
toward the end of my time,
but we do have some
time for questions,
and rewards for
people with questions.
So in my class I
actually ask people,
I not only ask, I force
people to ask questions.
So as a shareholder
in Google, I demand
that you ask me a question.
AUDIENCE: You think you're
doing but you're just
trying, how do you--
BERNARD ROTH: How do
you know the difference?
AUDIENCE: Is there a clear
way to tell the difference?
BERNARD ROTH: Well, I
mean, usually the results
will tell you.
So if you think you're
doing and suddenly you
realize nothing's
happening, as an example,
that woman if she's been
helping the people in Greece
for six months and nothing's
happening, she's trying.
So she has to stop Facebooking,
or whatever, take her money
and go there or whatever it is.
I don't know.
But I'm just saying it's
clearly not working.
So that's the
easiest thing you do.
It's just like my wife, we were
not getting into the theater
when the moment came,
so she was trying.
And doing is you do
it, you accomplish it,
so if it's just not
working, you'll know.
And actually, the interesting
thing is, to try takes force,
to do is power, and it's much
better to be powerful in life
than forceful in life.
And it actually takes
less force to, often,
than it does to try
because it goes,
it's like there's no
question about it.
When someone tries to take
this thing away from me,
we struggle, we fight,
but if they do it,
it's like an Aikido exercise.
I don't have a chance, I'm just
overwhelmed by the intention
to do it.
So it takes an intention
to do something
and you have to give
it some attention,
and if you do that, you're
doing it, it's as clear as that.
Otherwise just stay
home, "Oh, I wish,
I wish there was some way
I could--" that's trying.
Someone, yes, OK, let's see
if we can get to you next, OK.
But wait, I've got
to give her a reward,
I forgot my rewards,
one minute, one minute.
So, people who ask
questions-- you
sort of did before, so you get
a reward, and you get a reward.
And this, you can
put on your computer,
it will spread such
stuff and bullshit.
Here we go, there you go, you
get this and then you ask.
Go ahead, and you'll get one
anyway, because you already
earned one, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I think these
three concepts are pretty deep,
but the one where you
talked about asking yourself
the bullshit
questions, do you do it
only for the most
important ones, or the ones
that you are [INAUDIBLE] to,
or you just make it a habit
and paralyze yourself.
I'm just--
BERNARD ROTH: I'm
not understanding
what you are asking.
AUDIENCE: So if I'm going to
ask myself the questions of why
am I doing it,
why am I doing it,
for every small
thing which I do--
BERNARD ROTH: No,
no, no, no, no.
You're not asking
why you're doing it,
you're asking yourself--
if you're in Google,
here, you've done a lot of
good things in your life.
You didn't worry about
getting dressed this morning,
you got here, you didn't worry
about getting in the room,
you got here.
We do a million things we
never even think about.
But there are very
few things that people
like you and me lose sleep over,
that's what I'm talking about,
not everything.
If it works, leave it
alone, don't mess with it.
Do not mess with anything
that works in your life.
Please, OK?
I don't want everyone to say
I ruined-- leave it alone,
you're doing fine.
You're doing fine in
most of your life.
But we all have these little
things, that's what I'm saying,
those little things
are the ones if you
do that and say "What will it do
for me?" you'll get an insight,
it'll open up the
solution space,
and often it will solve itself
like my question about when
I should retire or not.
It takes care of itself.
You earned this from
before, but if you have
another question you could--
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I had a question that is
sort of about this, which
was the implication of
recognizing that everything's
a bullshit reason.
So I think I wasn't
sure whether you
were trying to say that
if somebody gives you
no and some reasons you
should realize that those
are bullshit reasons.
Or whether when
you're trying to get
somewhere, that your
reasons are bullshit reasons
and that rephrasing the
question will help you, or both.
BERNARD ROTH: What I'm saying
is that, the way you're built,
the way all of us are built
is we don't actually know.
This whole idea of there being
a reason for a specific behavior
is faulty.
There is not a reason
for specific behavior
since he and I could
have the same behavior
and have different reasons for
exactly doing the same thing.
And in fact, there is a
million reasons we've done it,
we have a different
history, and we can't figure
that all out, it's complicated.
It goes way back
to your childhood
and maybe when you
were in your cells,
and maybe back to
something some cells
that came out of
the Big Bang, who
knows why, I don't know why.
But it's so complicated
for your behavior,
it's not a simple thing
of cause and effect.
And when you make the simple
cause effect model, it's great,
it's functional, it makes
you a reasonable person,
and it's fine, keep it all
the time, don't mess with it.
However, there are times
when it gets in your way,
and you're letting
yourself off the hook.
You know, like she
got here because she's
in a distant building.
I don't care, it's not
that life and death,
but it's a good
example of this thing.
She got here because
she came late,
and she's late, that's all.
She doesn't know why she's late.
It could be, whatever
it is, I don't know.
It could be her parents
were always late,
it could be she
grew up in a culture
where the lateness didn't count.
I don't know, I don't know what
it is, and it doesn't matter.
All I'm saying is
take responsibility
for your behavior,
and don't let yourself
off the hook with reasons
because they're just excuses.
And if you label them as
excuses, you wouldn't do it.
And you're sugar coating it by
saying it's a reason, it's not,
and you don't know the reason,
that's what I'm saying.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
if you'd thought, maybe,
about the role of the poor and
thinking trying versus doing?
Is there any kind of
differences in say, maybe
a socioeconomically
disadvantaged person
couldn't buy movie tickets
to a sold out show?
Is it just limited
doing opportunities,
or how do you do that?
BERNARD ROTH: Well, everyone
has different strategies.
So if I'm a rich
guy I could buy,
if I'm a poor guy i could
steal, I don't know,
it's whatever-- I could
beg or I could to give you
a heart rendering story.
You know, "My brother's in
the theater and he's sick
and I have to, could I
please have your ticket?"
I don't know, whatever it
takes, that's the whole point.
There's no right answer
to it, it's just,
whatever it takes
I'm going to do it,
I'm going to get it done.
And often you feel
really proud of yourself,
I feel really proud that
I got those two tickets
and I'm telling the
whole world about it.
My wife hates when
I tell the story,
but it's so clearly that thing.
And there's no one
answer, and money may not
work in some cases, although
it often does work pretty well.
But it doesn't matter
what the answer
is, if you have a
technical problem to solve,
ammonium may not
work with that thing.
But some different way
of approaching it will,
and whatever it is.
I once had this experience, I
couldn't solve a math problem,
a very tough problem, and I
was going to give a talk on it
and I had given the
inflated title where
I could solve the general case.
I was, in my mind, getting
ready for the talk the next day
and I said, "the reason I can't
solve the general case is--"
And as I started
to give the reason,
it was clear I could
solve the general case.
But I had never let
go of the reason,
I realized it was
a bullshit reason,
so it even works
and technical stuff.
You don't know the
reasons for stuff,
you know what happens,
that's all you know.
And you don't need
to know the reasons,
the reasons are
nonsense, they're not
taking responsibility for
what the situation is.
Just use it a little
bit, you'll see,
it doesn't matter if you
believe me and it makes sense
or doesn't, just test it out.
The next time you're
about to give a reason,
if you don't have to, just stop.
Just say what's going on
and what you're going to do.
Anyone else?
Yes, how are you, the
stickers are going.
So here's this and here's this.
AUDIENCE: I was just thinking
that, potentially, reasons
also show for great companies.
Like companies without bullshit
reasons get things done,
and do you think that's
true, or have you
seen any examples of that?
BERNARD ROTH: Of what?
AUDIENCE: Good companies that
don't-- that have given up
reasons--
BERNARD ROTH: The whole company?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
BERNARD ROTH: It's too general
a question for me, I don't know.
You know, you get
it, actually, when
people get caught with their
fingers in the cookie jars.
Like, so when good
companies do something bad,
they'll generally admit
it and when bad companies
do something bad, they
generally give you
all sorts of reasons for it.
I don't know if that's true,
but that's sort of my idea.
In fact, you get that all
the time, even in politics.
Like Clinton and Nixon got into
more trouble by saying they
didn't do it than if
they said they did it.
You know, "I did it.
Something happened in the
Oval Office, I did it."
Or, Nixon, "Yes, we
had the burglars."
Just by not doing
it and they give you
all these reasons and stuff like
that, it just becomes messy.
But maybe people are getting
away with it all the time
and we just don't know about it.
OK, other questions?
AUDIENCE: It seems
like you could end up
being in a doing state, but
end up working on something
that is genuinely impossible.
You've never run into that?
BERNARD ROTH: You mean
something impossible?
AUDIENCE: Yeah--
BERNARD ROTH: Yeah, sure, sure.
AUDIENCE: Like I'm gonna
go to the sun [INAUDIBLE]
BERNARD ROTH: Well,
if you're working
on something that's
impossible, then you're never
going to solve it, right?
Is that your definition
of impossible?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess.
BERNARD ROTH: So the
question is, "What would it
do for you if you solved it?"
AUDIENCE: Oh, so you're
back to the first--
BERNARD ROTH: Well,
the idea is, let's
say you're working on something
you don't know is impossible.
Let's say a simple case.
Let's say it's impossible
for you to ever get married
because you have bad breath,
no one ever wants to marry you.
So no matter what you do, you're
never going to get married.
So the question is,
"What's it going
to do for you if
you go married?"
So if it's, "I'm going
to get companionship,"
well you can get a
dog, the dog might not
care about the bad breath.
Or if you hire
someone, enough money,
they don't care about
it, we know that.
So you're working
your way around it,
that constraint is gone
because somehow you
thought you were going to get
it out of getting married,
but you can get companionship
a lot of other ways.
So that's the idea.
AUDIENCE: I love that you
talked about the delineation,
the difference between
trying and doing,
and there are two real
stages that exist.
And you also mentioned
that most of the time we
don't know the reasons behind
why we're doing things.
So let's say you've been
on the journey for a while,
you've been trying,
and you've started
to identify some of those
reasons that are keeping you
from your-- like the four
things we worry about doing.
And you're starting
to feel kind of bad
about yourself, because
you know the reasons,
but you're not
making the changes
to get where you
want to go and be
an achiever or a
doer in these areas.
Can you comment
at all on-- what's
the breaking point,
what's the turning point,
is it different for everybody?
What's the transition
from trying to doing?
What does it look like?
BERNARD ROTH: So if
you're doing, no matter
what comes at you, you're
going to handle it.
If you're trying it may
work, but if something comes
at you to block you, you're
going to be deterred,
you're not going to do it.
So that's the difference
in the two states.
And you can see
what's happening,
and it's clearly you're
getting the result
or you're not getting results.
AUDIENCE: Right.
BERNARD ROTH: If you're
not getting the result
and you want to move
to the doing state,
you have to say "There's
this chair in front of me,
I have to walk around it."
And the chair may
be a person or maybe
the way you hold the world.
But the point simply
is, that the reasons are
just irrelevant,
they're not necessary,
they're not functional
at all, and mainly
they're just a way of
letting yourself off the hook
and blinding you as to
what the possibilities are.
AUDIENCE: I see.
I don't know if you
agree with this,
but what you are
saying at some level,
it's empowering that at
some level it's within us.
And doesn't mean we need
to blame ourselves, or be
hard on ourselves
overly, but you
talk about this frame of
mind where at some point,
"You know what, no.
It isn't my boss's fault, or
it isn't the universe's fault,
or this person's fault.
I just haven't gotten
to the point where I've made the
connections and the decision."
BERNARD ROTH: Well
what I call it,
you have to have the
intention to do it and give it
the attention.
So it's as simple as that.
A good example, I
was supposed to go
to a meeting, which I
didn't want to go to,
in Texas, in Dallas.
I got to the airport
in San Fransisco
and the guards were good to
me, the airports in Texas
were closed because
there was a snow storm.
So I called up and I say,
"Really, I'm sorry I can't go."
That's good, I went
home, I had a happy life.
If I really wanted
to go to Texas,
the fact that the
airport was closed
wouldn't have stopped me.
AUDIENCE: I see.
BERNARD ROTH: It's as simple
as if my life depended
upon getting to Texas, I
would've gotten to Texas even
though the airport was closed.
But they gave me a gift,
they gave me an obstacle
and I could just say
"I had a good reason."
and they didn't say it.
They didn't get this
whole idea that, "Yeah,
so the airport's
closed, man, but when
are you going to come here?"
You know what I mean?
If we were playing the
game at a high level,
"Yeah, well you were committed
to going to the meeting,
get here."
But they didn't
do that, so, whew.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, good stuff.
Thanks for being here, we've got
a few books left in the back,
the book is "The
Achievement Habit."
Dr. Roth, thanks so
much for being here.
[APPLAUSE]